more vegetables more Whole Foods less
added sugar and less refined grain those
are four of the biggest problems with
the U.S diet you don't eat many
vegetables we eat a lot of ultra
processed food create a crap ton of
added sugar and a crap ton of refined
grain we really all agree on those and
those are all big issues who own extra
one I'd love to add in there is beans I
actually think eating more beans is
probably
the biggest thing Americans could do to
change their diet in a positive way and
there's so many kinds of beans
culturally appropriate lots of
unapologetically delicious dishes with
lentils and chickpeas and kidney beans
and refried beans oh my god really like
if you do those four things and then
maybe the fifth with the beans like
you're on the five yard line